[Música]
los ucranianos conocen bien esta sirena
anuncia la inminencia de un bombardeo y
llama a la población a refugiarse
[Música]
estos habitantes se resguardan a 20
metros de profundidad en las catacumbas
de odessa unos 2500 kilómetros de
túneles este es alexander quien organiza
esta nueva vida bajo tierra
este tipo de refugio puede soportar una
bomba de una tonelada
esto es lo que los rusos están
utilizando en mariupol en este momento
durante el día son principalmente
mujeres y niños los que allí se refugian
todos estamos asustados quién no lo
estaría todos queremos seguir vivos
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa
los voluntarios como alexander han
estado entregando suministros e incluso
han establecido conexión de internet
para mantenerse informados
este gobierno
hemos aislado las paredes por si tenemos
que quedarnos mucho tiempo
pero esperamos que no
en los últimos días los ataques de los
barcos rusos a odessa han multiplicado
la ansiedad de la población
el domingo vimos las explosiones
estábamos lejos del refugio pero vinimos
corriendo aquí nos sentimos más seguros
no se oyó lo que pasa afuera y los niños
no se asusten lo que me asusta es que
dure mucho tiempo
en caso de un ataque a gran escala las
autoridades tienen la esperanza de que
las profundidades de las catacumbas
puedan salvar la vida de la población